estos avances del ejército ucraniano en
dos frentes A las afueras de bakud en el
norte y en el norte de la ciudad Se han
venido dando rápidamente y así lo
demuestran esos mapas que monitorean
minuto a minuto la guerra Allí se pueden
ver esos terrenos que han ido
recuperando las fuerzas de Ucrania ayer
se hablaba que eran al menos 16.5
kilómetros hoy habrían avanzado más pero
a esto se refirió esta mañana el
comandante de las fuerzas terrestres del
ejército ucraniano el general
que esto era un éxito parcial que había
que esperar lo que venía por delante
porque él advertía que la situación no
solamente era muy difícil sino que los
rusos estaban atacando con muchísimo más
potencial tanto en armas y en munición
como siempre lo ha dicho Ucrania eso
también venía en la línea de las
declaraciones de la vicepresidenta del
gobierno Hannah Meyer que hablaba de
esta
y también hablaba de las dificultades
que tenía el ejército ucraniano a pesar
de estos avances de los últimos días que
son los más importantes desde que Rusia
comenzó esta batalla por capturar esta
ciudad del Don vast hace 10 meses ellos
también hablaban de que la situación
dentro de la ciudad de es totalmente
diferente allí las fuerzas rusas siguen
teniendo el 90% del control de la ciudad
los ataques cada vez son más intensos
después de un parón de un par de días
han vuelto a intensificar y
especialmente a usar bombas incendiarias
con el objetivo de expulsar a las tropas
ucranianas que quedan por dentro y esos
ataques en el don Bach también se han
intensificado en otros lugares como en
la población
de hoy era atacado un hospital donde se
refugiaban civiles cuatro personas
murieron y también hoy para completar y
como para hacer un balance a esta
intensificación de la guerra en esta
parte del donbas se conoció que viene en
camino el enviado especial de China
que como se había hablado desde ya desde
hace semanas Busca una salida de
negociada un acuerdo de paz a esta
guerra viene aquí viene a Moscú y a
otras ciudades europeas